bond
james bond mr bond i suppose you
wouldn't care to um
raise the limit i have no objections
welcome to your weekly ticket
patrick wilson will step behind the
camera for insidious
five during blumfest 2020 blumhouse
announced wilson will be making his
feature directorial debut with the
sequel
he and ty simkins will reprise their
roles as josh and dalton lambert from
the first two insidious films
ncts 5 will pick up a decade after the
events of 2018's insidious the last key
and sees the lambert's son dalton
heading off to college
jordan peele will be producing a remake
of the people under the stairs for
universal
the 1991 horror satire that was directed
by wes craven
just celebrated its 29th anniversary
this past weekend
the original film followed a young boy
and two adult thieves who became trapped
in a house belonging to a strange couple
after breaking in to steal their rare
coin collection
peel will produce the new version of the
film for universal through his company
monkey paw productions
today we're highlighting the career of
sean connery whose career spanned five
decades and who passed away at the age
of 90.
he was best known for his portrayal of
james bond after being the first actor
to bring their role to the big screen in
1962's dr no
he went on to appear in a total of seven
of the spy thrillers
daniel craig who's the current bond paid
tribute to the star writing
sir sean connery will be remembered as
bond and so much more
he defined an era and a style the wit
and charm he portrayed on screen
could be measured in megawatts he helped
create the modern blockbuster
he will continue to influence actors and
filmmakers alike for years to come
this week we're diving into some of the
best spy films of all time by taking a
look at fandango now's list of spy films
across multiple genres
from historical gems to action-packed
blockbusters to absurd comedies
there's something for just about every
mood on their spy game staff
picks list this week we have comedian
host of the mad titan podcast and one of
my favorite guests that we've had on
this show
here to help us break this list down
that of course is
jay washington jay there is obviously a
lot to unpack here but what do you think
is your
number one must-see spy movie on this
list
my number one must-see spy movie is
kingsman the first one
and this is not a takeaway from taran
edges performers with colin firf
but the phenomenal samuel l
jackson not only do you get sam jackson
dressed up like
college sophomore ready to go to a rave
party as soon as he get through his
studies in the library
but you find out how villainous he
really
is and then he offers harry
mcdonald's
you understand how humble person you got
to be to offer somebody mcdonald's
you got to be real evil to do that i
mean they have the spicy nuggets now i
don't know
if that's the way i mean i think that's
even more heinous you're like i don't
care about your
gastrointestinal system at all there's a
lot of fun lore behind that movie too
didn't samuel jackson
decide to do the lisp himself wasn't it
i think it was his idea
that was his idea it wasn't in the
script you know it was like yeah we want
this character
to dress this way be this way and have a
list he was like no i'm just gonna live
for valentine because i think it's the
best thing for the characters to have
like what sir huh okay and it's iconic
it's great i love it the whole thing is
the church fight
with free bird in the background is
arguably
one of the greatest fight scenes i think
i've ever seen in any film
because it comes out of no you think
okay it's gonna be a few people
and the level of murder you if you're
like
oh oh oh you just like stuck with it so
kingsman is one of it's like my top one
of my favorites and if i had to give you
a close second it's the first mission
impossible of course
now obviously when people think spy
movies they think of
james bond now if you were looking
forward to the
last james bond with daniel craig you're
gonna have to wait a little bit longer
so what is an underrated bond movie that
you recommend
an underrated bond movie that i
recommend for you all to check out is
quantum masalas from 2008. it caught a
lot of flack because
it wasn't the traditional bond movie
this is the first
major blockbuster bond film and
also has way more violence
than any other bomb film beforehand
afterwards we're like we'll see a lot
more violence but it set the bar
for what the new level of violence was
this is our second go round
with daniel craig in the role he's
comfortable with it officially now
and we have so much action again you
give me jeffrey right again i am so
fine with that i'm so fine i was so mad
what happened with peter mathis's green
but that's another story now
let's say that someone is trying to get
into spy intrigue but
they don't want to necessarily watch a
james bond movie what's a great spy
thriller from this list that
doesn't have james bond in it a long
kiss good night samuel l
jackson and gina davis this is charlie
baltimore you gotta go there always man
like
that's an underrated movie in itself
like those who know the film they praise
it we love it
we consistently watch it but those who
have never heard of it when they first
get introduced to it they're like
wait why aren't there more of these
absolutely
well jay thank you so much you're
absolutely one of my favorite guests
that we have on this show
where can people find you twitter
instagram at mr j washington
also the man titan podcast like you
mentioned earlier and blurrs in the hood
myself and wednesday marshall every
tuesday and thursday live 2 p.m pacific
5 pm on the east coast
man nailed it all right man thank you so
much have a good one
available to watch in theaters on friday
is let him
go i saw exactly what i've always felt
about donnie weeboy
and i saw that girl can't protect her
child margaret jimmy's her boy
he's your grandson following the loss of
their
son retired sheriff george blackage and
his wife margaret leave their montana
ranch to rescue their young grandson
from a dangerous family living off the
grid in the dakotas headed by matriarch
blanche we boy
when they discover the wee boys have no
intention of letting the child go
george and margaret are left with no
choice but to fight for their family
academy award nominee diane lane and
academy award winner kevin costner star
[Music]
and available to watch at home on friday
is the informer
we go along with the general's plan
evidence of fentanyl being methodically
distributed inside a state prison buries
the general for good
and if that happens you're a free man
pete coslow is a former special
operations soldier
working as an informant for the fbi to
help dismantle the polish mafia's drug
trade in new york
but when the fbi's operation goes wrong
resulting in the death of an undercover
nypd
cop pete is coerced into returning to
bale hill
the prison he previously served time in
for manslaughter
to take down the cartel from the inside
the film stars joel kinnaman
ana de armas common and roseman pike
alright well that's it for today but
check out that full list of spy films in
the link below and leave us a comment
and let us know which one is your
favorite
i'm kale and i'll see you next
you